una inesperada tormenta afectó la isla
mediterránea de córcega granizo Fuertes
lluvias y Vientos de hasta 224
kilómetros por hora dejaron a su paso
muertos y heridos
también hay muertos en las partes altas
en la playa un pescador y otra víctima
que se encontraba en el mar el ministro
del interior francés lleva aldamarán
inspeccionó los daños en un camping
familias de vacaciones que perdieron a
sus seres queridos o cuyos seres
queridos resultaron heridos quiere
expresar todo el apoyo y la simpatías
del gobierno que ha estado trabajando
desde esta mañana
el clima extremo no sólo afecta a
Francia también a Italia donde dos
personas habrían perdido la vida tras el
temporal que azotó la Toscana Los
Fuertes vientos también afectaron la
plaza de San Marcos de Venecia y
ocasionaron desprendimientos en su
famoso campanario en contraste En una
isla siciliana los bomberos apagaron los
últimos los restos de dos incendios
forestales que obligaron a decenas de
personas a huir de sus Villas de
vacaciones durante la noche y en
Portugal los incendios no cesan más de
1.100 bomberos permanecieron en la Serra
de estrella donde reportaron el fin del
fuego vigilando los puntos calientes y
las brasas que pudieran ser arrastradas
a los bosques vírgenes el incendio
calcinó más de 26.000 hectáreas de
bosque para esta zona turística el
impacto es grave
desde el primer día del incendio
forestal se cancelaron muchas de las
reservas
en otros casos la gente estaba de camino
pero no pudieron llegar aquí porque las
carreteras estaban cerradas
en la vecina España de la unidad militar
de emergencias seguía en su lucha contra
el fuego en un incendio forestal en la
comunidad valenciana que ha consumido
unas 13.100 hectáreas